welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madnesses trailer promised
cameos are the highest caliber of
fanservice including of course the
off-screen voice of patrick stewart is
professor charles xavier from the x-men
films but think about it if they were
willing to reveal that you know there
are far crazier reveals that they are
still keeping under wraps much like the
decoy bunny suit we opened on christmas
morning concealing the true gift still
hidden that we will go so any [ __ ] for
that we will shoot our eyes out with it
many of these red riders can actually be
found on the official poster that was
released alongside the trailer which is
filled with dozens of broken shards that
if you match guy your peepers as
permanently as i have ah you can
actually reveal a ton of possible cameos
in this film so i'm gonna break down
everything hidden on this poster and
explain how they could fit into the
multiverse of madness plot now i've
already pointed out one huge sighting in
the lower right corner the union jack
shield of captain carter from what if
this movie looks like it is adapting
several elements from whatever into live
action and i've wondered if that sword
carrying warrior in the ring and
illuminati hq in the trailer could
actually represent captain peggy
carter's return from that portal in one
of episode 1 when she was carrying a
sword and that carter could actually be
one of the founding members of the
illuminati panel but an even more
surprising cameo may be found in the
upper left region of the poster a piece
with four sides a white dot in the
middle to the left of that dot some
claim you can see the image of deadpool
shushing us now maybe you didn't
actually see deadpool until i told you
deadpool was there my friends this is a
phenomenon called peridolia the human
instinct to see faces and familiar
shapes among chaos in which nothing
really is actually there but it does
gotta look like deadpool now i can't
unsee it because along with patrick
stewart professor x deadpool is one
other x-men character highly expected to
cross over into this film it was even
confirmed by deadpool creator rob
liefeld and deadpool was even confirmed
to get a third film of his own in the
mcu all we really needed was a
multiversal crossover event to establish
him in this universe now we got it now
ryan reynolds swears he's not going to
be in this movie tell me everything
about your appearance in the doctor
strange movie um yeah i don't i'm not
really supposed to i guess i'm really
not supposed to say anything about that
but i'm really not in the movie but uh
we've heard denials from werewolves like
him before the tone of this movie i will
say does seem darker more horror
grounded than the jokey metabug's money
attitude of deadpool but perhaps in a
post-credits scene or when strange in
america chavez tumble through realities
with the dinosaurs and an animated
cartoon reality you could easily imagine
deadpool get knocked loose and sucked
into that chaos crash-landing with them
wherever they land then like readjusting
his broken limbs and then skipping away
flipping them off now back to the poster
many of these pieces just show doctor
strange or his strange variants at
various angles strange can be seen in
the upper left corner and then on a
small blue piece at the top and then the
top half of his face a bit further down
from that then a triangular piece in the
upper right and then another rectangular
piece in the middle right and then one
small triangular piece to the right of
strange's body then there's a
desaturated strain to the middle left
region but with messy hair i think this
may actually be the sinister steven
strange you know him mr things have
gotten out of hand then in the lower
left corner a diamond-shaped piece
showing the eye of a rotting face
perhaps this is zombie strange from the
trailer in the tv spot who has the same
white stripes on his hair as the
defender strange we've been seeing he
actually shows up on a shard directly
above zombie strange's piece i'm
wondering if this heroic strange in the
movie may allow his life force to be
drained by the demonic entities that
feed off the melting realities i think
allowing his body to rot into a corpse
stage sacrificing himself to be taken
into darkness in order to damn that rift
now many of the other pieces show wanda
in her alternate forms because we know
there's gonna be at least two wandas in
this movie her scarlet witch form glares
at us from the left side and then at the
top of the poster a small four-sided
piece shows us wanda with her face
covered in blood as we see in that one
shot in the trailer nearby to the right
a thinner blue piece shows wanda with
her scarlet witch tiara once more as she
is in her seance in the trailer or when
she threatens strange in that hellish
setting that she reveals her orchard to
be a smokescreen for then wanda from a
similar moment shows up at a triangular
piece in the upper right region and then
a bit beneath that wanda once again in
the red glow to the right of strange but
notice here her eye wells up with tears
this could be wanda from her west view
house failing to recreate the reality
with her children and her crying face
actually shows up again directly to the
left of strange in the center of the
poster and then right above strange's
head is one small desaturated wanda but
her alternate self the one who i think
gets covered in blood but first special
thanks to extra the world's largest
smart wallet brand for sponsoring this
video they designed the smartest wallets
in the world which you can track with
their solar-powered tracker worldwide if
you ever have trouble finding your
wallet your tracker is here to help you
find it instantly it's voice activated
and solar powered two hours of sunshine
give it a three-month charge just
download the chippelo app on your phone
and you can ring your wallet from your
phone or your phone from your wallet it
works with google home alexa and siri
here's what i'm going to do i'm going to
slip the tracker in the wallet whoops
lost that
and then siri where's my wallet
oh
found it thanks extra oh and by the way
extra slim profile wallets are awesome
they're made of premium leather they
have rfid protection and you use this
little button on the side to instantly
fan out your cards so no more
overstuffed wallets no more giant lumps
in your back pocket so check out these
wallets with the link below and use
promo code rockstars for up to 25 off
site y at
slash new shop.exter.com
one that's code rockstars to maximize
your savings at
shop.exter.com new rockstars one now
other pieces show america chavez a red
piece in the upper left corner turned
sideways the star of her jacket shows up
near the top of the poster and then
below that her screaming mouth appears
on one piece and then along the right
edge of the poster another piece shows
her fierce gaze now mordo shows up three
times first on the far left then
screaming on the blue piece at the top
and then his eyes are seen on a
triangular piece in the center and wong
shows up twice along the far left edge
of the poster and then on a blue piece
in the upper left region christine
palmer shows up in the upper right
region in her wedding dress looking over
her shoulder at us like i'm the one who
got away but it also looks a bit like
christine and the shard in the middle
left of the poster but not the same
christine as the one on her wedding day
this one's wearing that blue outfit and
the white lab coat one who shows up in
the tv spot working in the detention
room of illuminati hq now there are a
few sightings on this poster that look
like a book or a spell book maybe the
dark hole that we see doctor strange
using in this trailer what looks like
the darkhold's cover is on the left side
of the poster beneath that big red piece
of strange and then directly beside
strange's raised hand in the center of
the poster another that looks like it
could be the cover of a book also at the
very top of the frame is the image of
the broken face of doctor strange's
wristwatch now in the middle left of the
poster is a broken triangular piece
showing a monstrous eye i'm pretty sure
this is the eye of gargantos the squid
monster and obscure namor villain who
attacked strange in america in the
street though i love how this triangular
piece frames the eye forming the
freemason symbol of the all-seeing eye
associated with the illuminati
conspiracy theory but then to the lower
left of that eye we see a statue head of
that minotaur sorcerer who is the
interdimensional being from the comics
intro now there are a few more that are
just really hard to make out and you
could argue or anything in the marvel
world but there is one tiny piece in the
middle between the bigger pieces of
mordo strange america and wanda it looks
like the glowing eye and the head of one
of those ultron sentries and then to the
lower left of the poster right to the
left of the defender strange piece there
is part of the body like the chest torso
showing the cree uniform design of
captain marvel but i am wondering if
this could be the sigil for photon with
either monica rambo or maria rambo
showing up in this movie now if we were
to zoom back from all this the breaking
glass aesthetic is totally a visual
inspired by the recurring opening
credits of what if which depicted the
multiverse as broken pieces of glass
something that the animators came back
to in the final episodes as ultron
infinity and the watcher dueled smashing
through universe after universe and
since multiverse of madness looks like a
live-action version of what if i think
it is fitting that a possible little
watcher cameo appears framed in the
contours of this poster the way the
watcher silhouette would just blend in
with the sky you could see what i think
is him between the pieces of america and
wanda the broken glass forms the curve
of his head and his earlobe and then
nearby a thin white piece forms his
squinting eye as he watches all of this
madness unfold helpless to do anything
about it what cameos did you spot in
this poster you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
new rockstars and subscribe to rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching watcher
[Music]
foreign